Do you want to kick all the immigrants out of Spain say?
Well,
no.
We welcome
to those who come to work with us
side by side,
legally,
in an orderly manner,
respecting our laws,
adapting to the way we live.
We welcome you.
What's more,
I know that here today,
as in all the events we are celebrating,
there is a tremendous amount
of Spanish Americans,
of those sister nations
of Colombia,
of those sister nations of Cuba,
of Brazil,
of Venezuela,
of all those places
where people live,
with whom we share a language,
with whom we share common history,
with whom we share values
and with which we share today
our rejection of criminal socialism
that has ruined its people,
that has taken away their freedom
and that has caused them to emigrate.
Welcome all of them.
But of course,
we do not welcome
to human trafficking mafias
nor to those who come here demanding rights
that our children cannot have.
We are not going any way
accept that human trafficking mafias
are subsidized
with the public money of all Spaniards,
nor will we allow
that our borders be a sieve